hey friends and welcome back to rapid  fire language learning today we're  exploring the question how to make  language learning happen every single  day  if there's a secret to effective  language learning it's this make it  happen  every single day for a long period of  time but it's actually easier said than  done  you want to remove the friction of  actually getting started because that's  where the problem is  so here's my piece of advice make sure  that every weekend you separate  planning from actual learning every  weekend you will plan exactly which  resource you're going to use  when you're going to use it for how long  you're going to be using it and  how you're going to be using it and this  change alone i promise  can make a big difference in the long  run if you want to know more about  language learning in general  and how to learn languages better and  faster please  check out my channel over and out